oh [ __ ] we got a debate club this this
young man went to a trump rally or what
king and esteem what up my name is
hunter and yes i realize i look
extremely swollen wisdom teeth
and this has to do with part of my
debate club so
the reason i'm so swollen and look like
a freaking bloated italian who just
drowned and came back to life
thick boy bike club it's because i just
had
all four of my wisdom teeth removed and
honestly
i'm still a little high from the meds so
uh i thought it'd be a good idea to send
in a video
but yeah getting your wisdom teeth
removed
you get all four out or do you do what
some people have done
that ancient neanderthal baby that
primal that primal man
and do you leave all four of these
suckers in
what's it gonna be yeah in all
seriousness though
you guys have uh honestly inspired me a
lot i love the fighter and the kid
and i love uh this past weekend uh from
both you guys it's really motivated me a
lot and i hope to one day make a
difference in this world
and honestly become a guest on you guys
podcast so um
yeah gang gang buzz buzz wisdom teeth
removal
well we got a chair open on firing the
kids
too soon dude bro you could easily call
it the fighter in the cavities right now
in a hot beat
rope obviously this dude lost the final
bout in karate
kid i'm gonna go out and say that
yeah he does no man look it's very kind
to you bro
yeah shout out to you man that's just
like sting
i'm saying something nice to this guy oh
sorry man
thank you very much for the nice message
and also brendan this guy really looks
like it could be your son
from the future sending you a video you
might be right
did you even think about that you might
be right so
uh thank you bro for the support of the
podcast it's really tough when all of
our friends are sex offenders
to stay in business um
it's exhausting it's exhausting yeah
accused sex offenders and that's really
what i'm
doing just joking um i mean we got more
proof on guys in this room than any
either two of those dudes
oh you looking at me dude huh we'll see
what that medium says jen
yeah jim and nick real stressed brother
you know we couldn't find them dude
they're pretty busy
oh yeah so i don't believe that [ __ ]
anyway man that'd be a bad episode
nick subtly slips into this episode that
he has sexual allegations on this
dude if you google me it's not even me
bro it's like some guy looking for lot
lizards and [ __ ]
silences of the way you got to get out
in front of it
that's true that came to his defense
real bad oh it's [ __ ] [ __ ] dude
you google it
none of it's real you guys know this um
google has a liberal agenda i love how
also nick pulls up the wrong guy from
karate kid as well
i haven't seen it you haven't seen
karate kid
i saw the one with jaden smith
i think i saw it once but the the new
series on youtube bread is killing it no
again do you know what i'm talking about
don't you ralph macho
thank you oh the karate kid he won you
said the guy who lost at the end of
karate kid
no he said he was saying if he lost if
he lost
original karate kid and i don't even
know what i said nick so i'm sorry
daniel's son i'm just i'm [ __ ] around
of gas twice in one week and i'm 40.
so i'm not doing that good but um damn
he also looks like my son
and yeah daniel's son your son
tiger son wow i'm gonna say right now
um this guy's question was
wisdom teeth all four at a time who has
wisdom teeth in here
i still have mine me too like the
[ __ ] lord intended bro
you still have them [ __ ] dude chris got
hard hearing you say that first of all
um i can't believe you still have your
wisdom to eat
hell yeah dude i'm just joking is that
like a young person thing
i don't know if i have mine or not you
do not have yours i have mine in no
way and that's why my teeth that's why
my my bottom teeth look like city
skyline because it's pushing them in
well i got mine like that cincinnati
chili huh yeah doug
that [ __ ] well so who has nickna
you got yours removed no i still have
mine [ __ ] yeah you're a man
now in asian cultures is it popular to
get your wisdom teeth out it seems like
that seems like a very american thing no
it is because it makes your face more
v-line
that's why i love that that sounds like
a rich asian thing
i know the girls that have gotten their
wisdom teeth removed that are vietnamese
my friends
their face changed so they all want to
get removed no more
isn't that so thirsty
what is that thirsty rich asians is that
what it's called i think so it's called
crazy rotations my bad thirsty rich
asian sounds way better yeah
that sounds like a porn i would watch
that yeah
i'm not watching any more porn again
good for you um
relapse again huh you had a relapse i
mean i just can't handle it
i just can't handle it keep them 32 68
bunch of [ __ ] god gave them to us for
a reason man i left my [ __ ]
in you're riding those rock sockets dude
i had to get them out because i was
getting infected
yeah so like i had to they were like you
gotta get another thing trying to take
down the black man that's what i said i
was like these white
teeth
with these white bro it hurt it hurts to
hear it dude i'll take whatever
whatever it takes to get this face
scanner here i'm sick of having these
junk
chunky monkey face nothing the teeth
isn't going to help dude
that's what you just said it'd make your
face look like something tell us more
about this i don't know why anybody
interrupted you
i wish i could take mine out because my
face could be a little thinner
wow i think that's head though chin my
head's big but i mean it does make a
difference when it goes from
like a v line but what do you what do
you think when you hear that kat when
you hear somebody say that
i'm so sad there's nothing wrong with
your face or your face
i have a fat face yes you do but that is
and you've got yours taken out
you also do i don't know if i did or not
i've been put to sleep a lot by men
maybe that's what happened when you were
23. it's your wisdom teeth
there it is against my will yeah maybe
you want me to keep it
play with dang dang i have to ask my mom
wait nick you have yours i do damn
everybody has them
oh i'm the only one that's got a mouth
no theos is out i will
i'm missing i think too how many do you
have four
only four well it depends how big your
mouth is if you're if your mouth can
support that's your teeth you can leave
them
uh that sounds like something that yeah
that's what they say
really yours are out cat nicks you have
like a strong chin so is your mom
i don't know if that's a good thing
that's a good idea that's a good thing
yeah that's a good thing brandon
shouldn't have said that nice
that's a good thing it's an attractive
thing yeah thank you
yeah kat i think your face looks very
well structured and nice
as i do think everybody's facing here
almost everyone
and i think that uh that
i it makes me sad also chin that you
want to get your teeth taken out to look
different
to look like a young woman i wanted to
do it before but now
i'm more accepting of my face well i
still want to do it
you do brendan what are you going to do
with it i don't know i just found out
this information makes your face skinny
it contours it yeah
dude don't you see though look at the
hill you guys are going down first you
know
your buddy gets his eyes you know sucked
off or whatever
oh you're trying to get his lids done
yeah that was a bad idea
but then where does it start it starts
with the teeth and you get the [ __ ]
elbows rounded it never ends
yeah you know then you're [ __ ] you
know then maybe we can get three for one
does it hurt you
do your teeth hurt you not at all
literally just doing it to
have a skin in your face your belly and
then brennan you you get meds afterwards
too
and i love men i threw mine away
you're mad yeah i'm like i ain't taking
it how long have you thrown them away
[ __ ] white hills this was years ago
were they white pills too
yeah they were white oh yeah yeah i was
like these white
pills going down the toilet years ago
years ago hurts my heart like 27. if you
told me you did a week ago
you'd see him at your house this week
video of it on my own
he's definitely been he seemed like he's
been jay's got his taken out his face
still pretty
i fast know if this is true i'll show
you through all this pain
i'll show you a girl a picture of a girl
who had it before i mean had her teeth
in and took it out and see how her face
shines
your friend's full of [ __ ] she had no
teeth taken out but then she also got
that kylie jenner
no no yeah it makes me sad when i hear
that jen because i think yeah
to getting that to adjust your face but
also if it makes you happy dude
yeah [ __ ] what i think and you're
supposed to take them out anyways right
no i don't know where that nerve got
started if you have to take them out
if they rotten yeah so a lot of people
they get infections like chappelle yeah
yeah i was gonna it was like getting
infected it helps me grind the food
better
it's just money dentists just want more
money that's what they say you know
dentists number one job commits suicide
why because they're not [ __ ] teeth
all day probably because they've been
pulling teeth out of people's mouths
that don't need them pulled out and if i
did that for five years i'd take my own
life they wanted to be doctors
but they're staring at teeth yeah but
every now and then they'll sneak around
and pull something out of your leg or
out of your [ __ ]
hip yeah i play with your ding-dong
while you're under medicine oh you got a
[ __ ]
you got a molar in under your dick yeah
they'll sneak they'll be like oh you got
a [ __ ] incisor and you do it was like
right after them every wednesday and get
put to sleep
they were like damn you got to overbite
in your ass
we found a cavity in your [ __ ]
yeah you're like that is a cavity yeah
that is a county dog
so what are you doing in there
why are we behind the movies
[Music]